all right welcome welcome everyone for
the Tuesday evening class first class
and this game and this lecture I'll be
showing you my game against a very
strong Grandmaster from England David
Howe who is actually right now
2,700 so he made some good progress as
you can see you know I'm still around
26:50 you know so I play David eight
years ago in a way concert tournament
the famous Tata Steel tournament and
this is the big group the winner of this
group qualifies to the a group so okay
so I was looking forward to this
tournament d4 Knight f6 c4g 693 defy
David is a very very popular group of
player and I knew that he will probably
take the groover because that's his main
opening he usually just placed that so
no surprise here we have the opening
hold everybody groom fell defense one of
the most dynamic and sharp openings you
can have so this is a very very
interesting opening so there are many
different ways how you can play against
groom Phil so I decided to play see
takes d5 go to one of the main lines
takes e4
93 BC Bishop g7 Knight f3 Bishop III
okay I play this many times and you
really have some good games with this
set up you know so the next one is 25
putting pressure and White's next move
is pretty much forced Queen d2 because
otherwise when he does CD you're not
gonna have a you're not gonna have a
good way to capture back so that's why
stay here
96 activating the knight and putting
pressure on d4 here so why it has two
options here two moves basically you can
play here so what do you think are the
two main moves are here yeah well if I
would be a brutal mistake yeah not just
mistake it would be a brutal mistake you
know because you will basically lose
lose everything here so you don't want
that so what you will do here you don't
want to play that so Isis
yeah here no
I mean you you wanna you want to sort of
play d5 here so can you make a move to
prepare that Adi absolutely Rd yes Roxy
one is one move and the second move here
I played this route b1 the point of
route B one I want to be able to play
rugby five now okay and if he takes on
default I just take back with a pawn so
David canceled and go for this line
there is a forcing line rook c5 Oh bleep
I see takes d4 rook takes a5 they take
only 323 Knight a5 so it's a Queen
sacrifice Queen sacrifice just want to
go back and everybody can see that so if
it castles rook b5 sorry Oh p5 if it
moves the Queen I just take rook c5 and
I'm just a pawn so it takes take take
now we have this interesting position
here so I want to see what do you think
of this position why people go for this
because this position has been played
many many times what do you think the
evaluation of this position is so first
we need to understand what's going on
with the material imbalance so why it is
a queen versus a Queen and Bishop right
so we have a material imbalance here so
what are we gonna do so first I want to
see everybody mention who you think is
better and why give reasons
well black has a rook and a bishop for
the Queen rook and a bishop is three
plus five eight so technically speaking
I'm up upon but there are some
weaknesses in a position that I have
okay there are some weaknesses in a
position yeah and black has two bishops
yeah
yes excellent point the SI phan is a
weakness okay it's gonna be a problem
for a long time and that's why you know
this position black has a compensation
again I haven't looked at this position
since that game so this was eight years
ago so probably current computers are
much stronger they will give you a more
clear assessment but one thing I can
tell you
doesn't look like black goes for this
anymore
so this position has been played 58
times in the history of the game and so
the highest-rated guy who went for this
is Alex's Sheriff Peter Svidler played
anyway so quite a few players here so
here there are basically two moves main
move is Knight f3 to d4 and h4 okay so
we go back to my game I play Knight d4
still following the theory my opponent
played Bishop d7
just developing the bishop to connect
the rooks and I play e5 so we have 18
games played so far and now he played
rook fc8 rook fc8 okay I will close this
we don't need this so anyway what about
ten for ten or so games played here now
what should I try to do here I played
this Knight d4 if I because I wanted to
block a the diagonal okay so that's why
I want to make sure the diagonals back
but now my pawns are bit Lucy now Lucy
here Lucy here they both bit loose here
so what to do in this position what to
do to strengthen the position here
our fishing
absolutely ashish f for strengthening
the position strengthening that Center
okay Roxy seven
so she's just gonna double up
now yeah he wants to double up to see
double up to Luke's and then it's going
to be a problem for me to defend this
one so and also he opponent his the pair
of the bishops and we know that when
opponent has pair of the bishops what
should we try to do open it up and now
what is the move that is going to give
us the option to open it up who can do
it huh ah dick absolutely
developing the bishop and putting
pressure ninety six and now
yes Bishop c6 Bishop takes c6
now the question is what are we gonna do
are we gonna take that picture but we're
gonna leave it on the board think think
so you can make the right decision the
correct decision okay
yes
there are two reasons we have to take
that bishop is very strong on the light
squares and also he has the pair of the
bishops we don't want those two bishops
remain there okay so that's why you take
he takes kinky - if you Castle your king
is too far away from the weaknesses and
you run into risk of some kind of
fortress with e6 Bishop f8 and plus
you're going to be attacked on this
diagonal but instead I go here I want to
try to use my rook to defend
so he goes b6 because if he moves the
rook I can take this pawn so if he goes
here I capture it captures I gerak d1
okay so you face b6 now now what you
gonna do here think
now what piece needs to be you have to
bring into the game here can't perfect
threaten to play rock d7 it goes through
kc8
yes
Rock T 3
now he plays f6 but if six weakens the
position right I think it would be more
resilient to clearly each six or Bishop
f8 I think but now afraid they have six
he wants to get some counter play what
should I do
yes
Queenie for first Ashish because I know
he's gonna take only five I want to be
able to play f5 ideas right and now I
have some light-square ideas as well so
he takes f5 keeping his dark square
Bishop locked in and trying to attack
him on the light squares opening up that
King he played g5 now
we need to open up that king adi context
f6
yeah but i don't think i just want to
give up the pawn my death at g5 pawn
ashish of course h4 putting pressure he
takes
check now he cannot go to a fade because
I take so he has to go to the corner and
now
you need to make a strong move here who
can find the strong move here what more
did I play here huh well the problem is
the queen is hanging what about
activating the queen queen each six guys
because now if he takes on c3 look at
that
aha so by doing this I'm stopping him
from taking so he plays rook g8 trying
to trade now what you gonna do Rd rogue
h3 is rook g7 I take
and now
he's trying to set up a fortress g4 g5
rook c6 okay because if it moves the
bishop I have a queen e6 check and
everything now so in this position it's
very important moment here so of course
I can take the bishop right away but
it's not so simple
or I can try to do something else
activate I mean he is trying to his his
ideas to try to come up with a fortress
so what to do here yes Ken g6 I think he
just takes g6 he takes yeah but how do
how do you you cannot just meet with the
Queen yeah yeah you cannot just meet
with a queen you need more pieces no I
don't well if you take with the pawn the
problem is again you only have a queen
and you're gonna have a hard time
meeting me
you're gonna check but I'm gonna go here
h1 here look g6
Thanks well okay we could do that guys
but it's not so clear g6 something else
you have here you can try to activate
before taking the bishop you can
activate something first long-range move
needed can yes
long-range move attacking the rook first
and there are some light-square
weaknesses rook d6 takes and he wants to
keep the rook there but okay first I
have to get some pawns now the point
here is if if I win the beasts expand
I'm gonna win easily but he's just gonna
sit there okay so he's just gonna sit
there on the sixth rank so first I try
to get this other pawn
I pay for fixing in alright who is gonna
be able to find the solution here the
question is what's the plan here
it's very nice plunder you know
it's it's what is the plan here can I
pick him before so he has to move the
rook right now I go Queen see it first
protecting now he goes h5 because he has
to push the pawn otherwise my king is
coming to b5 yeah my king is coming to
see far let's say he doesn't do anything
let's say he goes here right I go here
and now what's the winning plan
calculate your King and pawn and games
guys Queen takes
you stopped yeah so that's why he played
h5
now I go back here to defend a tactic
and he resigned here because what's
gonna happen he's gonna lose that pawn
so he will go here and he will lose the
pawn and guess the winning plan is go
back to the same thing so I will go here
but the difference now it doesn't even
have the past pawn so here it's easier
because now I go here and then you push
the pawn okay five six so he no he
actually resigned after I won the pawn
he resigned yeah he resigned right here
because if he goes backwards it's even
worse you know
right
all right so that's the game okay all
right now we're gonna do some medium
difficulty puzzles okay white to play
and win male teen Wroblewski game okay
male teen Rublev ski correct so this is
from the 2016 Russian rapid Cup
championship why to play and win yes six
moves calculation one two three four
five six
please dink take your time and then only
then when you have all the moves raise
your hand
it's very very concrete as you can see
ya can know I made you I take check if
you go here can I check check check
so don't think I'm just defending I'm
not only defending I'm also trying to
attack I'm looking for an offense - yes
aha aha excellent has to take right now
and the mainly thread can whatever you
do can you got to do it with the check
okay yes he can't go here because we
have a nice four key okay
so he has to go here now calculate
everything okay everything
check
check
check
yeah
all right and now the king king goes
here thank you very much
exchanging the Queens if he goes here
again you take this and you take the
Queen okay so it's very interesting
so again but this block probably felt
good about it he probably thought maybe
he's gonna win this now because his his
threats are very strong you know he's
got Queen coming I mean his you know
very powerful threat so he probably felt
good about his chances here but then
black comes up you know comes in with
strong counter play here and and then he
he turns the tables you know he turned
the tables with g4
very powerful move hitting the Queen has
to take it what are the other options
he can go here here if he goes here just
trade check and take okay so he cannot
go h4 I take here I texture has to go
here
and now
so if he goes here so what's the idea
and I can even take - yeah just made the
next book check second mate all right he
takes continued
that's a nice book that's a nice
deflection okay and now check if he goes
to g8 you have 9h six so he goes here
continue check check you're actually
forcing him to take your night you want
to get rid of him because now when he
takes back you take it with a check
continue if it goes to defy you take
this and if it goes here
so win it again so once again remember
not over is when you get a position like
this not always you have to look for the
check check capture moves sometimes
you're gonna have positions like this
where you need to come up with a move
like g4 okay sometimes you're gonna need
to do that remember that okay you're
gonna need to do that sometimes to have
this the breakthrough okay so remember
that g4 is very very important okay okay
great
we're gonna take a short break now and
get ready for the next class okay
[Music]